the policy muscle
like I love to cook so
turns out buddy Snowden sit down a way
to take great food and push it into a
missing
myself sitting
laws
southern drugs
because
my students who are 16 17 and 18 years
old we're spending time in Adult jail
that overall both the actual conditions
but also the impact of leaving with a
felony as opposed to adjudication just
really set up young people for recycling
back into the system okay what do you do
anything at 16 so how is it that you can
go spend time with real adults with like
as speaking as a man like how could I at
sixteen gold spend time with
top my age
and expect them to teach me something as
many times it was seen that inside of
the jail cell
and the boat Rikers Island boat oh my
god
ever going back
same changes
don't see become shot the light
sad to say jumping disabled
you